[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à la
découverte de Houdan une ville
historique médiévale située à l'ouest du
département à la frontière
d'Eure-et-Loir ou dans vous offre une
jolie balade entre ville nature et
histoire de France on retrouve des
traces depuis l'époque néolithique mais
elle fut vraiment peuplée à partir du
12e siècle avec son donjon ses auberges
ces commerces atypiques ont vous guide à
travers ces rues et on part tout de
suite à la rencontre de Loïc pioche
c'est le dirigeant de la boucherie des
arts c'est le seul à vendre encore le
fameux pâté de Houdan
[Musique]
bonjour alors vous êtes le gérant de
cette boucherie et vous êtes le seul à
commercialiser encore le fameux pâté de
aux dents et qu'est-ce qu'il a de
spécial ce passé
à base de viande de volaille de la poule
de Houdan 100% voilà il n'y a pas de
gelée de porc à base de pistache
munition de champignons avec vin blanc
et un petit peu de cognac et c'est 100%
voilà et vous avez beaucoup de clients
qui vous en demandent du coup pas mal
depuis qu'on a fait la confrérie il y a
4 ans le concours on a une deuxième prix
et on a eu beaucoup de monde par rapport
à ça et tous les semaines on a des gens
qui viennent de loin pour acheter des
boutons
et je suis avec l'un des experts des
spécialités culinaires deux ou dans le
vice-président de la Confrérie du pâté
et de la poule de Houdan Didier Viot
bonjour bonjour Mathilde expliquez-nous
c'est quoi l'histoire de cette confrérie
pourquoi une confrérie tout simplement
pour ne pas que ce pâté de Houdan
disparaisse et nous avons eu en 2016 on
va dire quatre amis et moi-même l'idée
de monter une confrérie donc une
confrérie gastronomique de la poule et
du pâté de Houdan riche au soudanais on
va dire c'est un pâté qui a été inventé
à la fin du 19e siècle et pour ne pas
que ça tombe dans l'oubli et bien on a
eu l'idée de monter cette confrérie et
qui aujourd'hui et bien va visiter
d'autres confréries se faire connaître
et faire découvrir ce fameux pâté de
Houdan et donc vous avez aussi également
un uniforme un costume c'est une tenue
une tenue c'est une tenue donc dans les
confréries on suit on va dire un code
couleur entre guillemets vous avez donc
les couleurs qui représentent la
confrérie à travers on va dire le noir
de la de la poule de Houdan la petite
dorure que vous voyez qui représente le
la croûte du pâté de Houdan nous avons
ajouté sur nos épaules ce côté vif qui
représente aussi la crête de la poule et
du coq et bien merci beaucoup Didier
pour toutes ces informations et bien de
rien et bienvenue merci
prenons le temps de se balader dans les
rues du centre-ville nous sommes tout de
suite plongés à l'époque médiévale les
auberges rue de Paris témoignent du
passé ville étape durant le Moyen-âge
[Musique]
et l'église Saint-Jacques et Saint
Christophe surplombe la place du
centre-ville elle est classée monument
historique
[Musique]
à 5 minutes à pied le chemin de la croix
aux pèlerins vous offre une jolie
promenade en pleine nature au bout un
magnifique panorama sur la ville
[Musique]
il est midi c'est l'heure de la pause
déjeuner je vous propose qu'on aille
faire un petit tour des restaurants de
la ville
[Musique]
bonjour madame bonjour est-ce que c'est
possible pour manger pour une personne
s'il vous plaît
je vous propose pas de madame
je vous propose la carte des spécialités
fromagères donc avec les tartiflettes
fondues un étérable et vendeur chaud
on a une carte traditionnelle des plats
du jour et avec des produits de saison
avec des produits de saison
[Musique]
c'est excellent
activité historique incontournables le
donjon de Houdan enceinte fortifiée
durant le Moyen Âge son vécu est
intimement liés à l'histoire de France
c'est parti on part à sa découverte
[Musique]
des prés bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
animatrice du patrimoine et vous vous
occupez notamment de ce donjon quel est
son histoire alors le donjon a été
construit à la fin du 12ème siècle c'est
ce sont les dernières fouilles
archéologiques qui nous le disent qu'il
a été construit par la famille des monts
d'accord on pense que il n'était pas
habité parce qu'il y a pas de cheminée
ici
on pense que c'était pour montrer une
puissance féodale forte sur la région
c'était peut-être aussi une tour
d'observation parce que on est il est
très très bien elle est très très bien
placée cette tour mais on pense aussi
que
pas forcément à des fins militaires
parce qu'il y a pas d'éléments de
défense active qui nous indiquerait que
c'était un fort donc on pense plutôt
voilà que c'était une identité féodale
forte pour surveiller l'ennemi oui alors
de là-haut effectivement on a une très
bonne vue à 360 degrés donc sans doute
c'était une tour de guet mais il n'y a
pas de machine au lit mais il n'y a pas
de chemin de ronde il n'y a pas de
meurtrière donc c'est ce qui nous fait
penser que c'était pas vraiment un
bâtiment militaire mais plutôt un
bâtiment
d'apparat le donjon de Odin propose
également des concerts des expositions
ou encore des escape game pour faire
vivre ce lieu d'histoire
[Musique]
autre symbole de cette commune la foire
sans Matthieu c'est l'une des plus
vieilles foires d'Europe cette année aux
dents fête ça 952e édition aux couleurs
de l'Afrique elle a lieu la troisième
semaine de septembre
[Musique]
que serait aux dents sans ces
producteurs et agriculteurs avec 77%
d'espace agricoles la commune dispose de
7 grandes exploitations Stéphanie van
halte cultive avec son mari une variété
de fruits et légumes de saison vous
pouvez retrouver leurs produits en vente
directe à la ferme fraîcheur garantie
[Musique]
après cette journée bien remplie je suis
un petit peu fatiguée alors je vous
propose qu'on aille voir où est-ce qu'on
peut dormir
j'ai trouvé mon endroit pour passer la
nuit le moulin 1826 et je suis en
compagnie de Marc bobion bonjour bonjour
vous êtes du coup le gérant de cette
chambre d'hôte le propriétaire et chef
cuisinier dans le restaurant quelle est
l'histoire de cet endroit 1826
c'est un moulin qui était qui a été
construit en 1826 sur la vegre la
rivière qui passe ici qui a été exploité
environ pendant une centaine d'années
jusque dans les années 1920 puis après
c'est devenu une maison d'habitation
voilà moi j'ai racheté ce moulin en
2020 juste un mois avant le confinement
le premier confinement nous a permis de
faire les travaux et depuis voilà on
exploite le restaurant une trentaine de
places et la chambre d'hôtes 4 chambres
pour une dizaine de couchages OK et du
coup c'est quels sont les prix au niveau
des chambres d'hôtes on est entre 85 et
95 euros en fonction de la saison
puisqu'on a une piscine à disposition de
nos clients et au niveau du restaurant
on est sur des entrées entre
8 et 10 euros des plats entre 16 et 20
euros et des desserts à 7 euros vous
servez quoi du coup comme type de plat
cuisine assez traditionnelle
très lisible des produits de saison on
change la carte tous les mois 5 entrées
cinq plats qui changent voilà
régulièrement
j'espère que vous avez passé un bon
moment avec nous à la découverte de
Houdan j'ai trouvé cette ville et ses
habitants très accueillants moi ce que
j'ai préféré c'est la balade sur le
chemin de la croix au pèlerin en
attendant je vais vous laisser ici j'ai
bien mérité un peu de repos
[Musique]